effectivement Grégory 54e édition du
Salon aéronautique et de l'espace au
Bourget et première édition pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et je suis
avec Jean-Michel fourgon ce président de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonjour
bonjour Alors premier édition première
participation c'était important d'être
présent ici sur ce salon au vu du
secteur aéronautique et de sa dimension
sur le territoire de 50 ans Yvelines et
bien d'abord les Renault tik c'est la
fierté française
dans le monde c'est c'est là où l'image
de l'ingénierie l'excellence française
et bien présenté
les secteur dans le commerce extérieur
qui qui nous sauve quand on vient
d'apprendre 500 commandes d'Airbus c'est
une des plus grosses commandes depuis
plusieurs décennies ça montre bien que
la France le talent français ça existe
et c'est nos ingénieurs bien sûr qui qui
portent haut et effectivement
Saint-Quentin et et à 12 000 emplois
de l'aéronautique avec des très belles
signatures soit airbuste à l'Est
d'assaut enfin que ce soit Atos soit
safran il y a une cinquantaine
d'entreprises liées à l'aéronautique
donc bien entendu on est très fier aussi
de d'être dans ce merveilleux
je dirais combat de haute technologie
d'excellence entrepreneuriale donc ça
fait rêver les enfants d'ailleurs c'est
les enseignes qui plaisent le plus aux
jeunes qui sortent des écoles donc on
est très fier d'avoir sur nos territoire
bien entendu et de porter et moi-même
j'étais le député pendant 15 ans qu'on
m'appelait le dépôt de l'aéronautique
parce que je défendais au niveau
national et dans ma et dans mon
territoire de Saint-Quentin aussi et
déjà l'aéronautique donc
ça ça me passionne c'est c'est ça fait
réussir mon pays et les emplois du haut
de valeur ajoutée des emplettes très
stratégiques mais quand vous vendez
même à l'étranger un avion vous faites
rentrer aussi d'autres plus riche
française voyez d'autres donc c'est
important c'est un ambassadeur
extraordinaire du talent français oui
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire il y a
des grands groupes des têtes d'affiches
qui sont présents sur le territoire de
50 ans en Yvelines mais il y a aussi des
PME des sous-traitants parfois de ces
grands groupes mais aussi des startups
des centres de recherche on pense à
l'ESTACA au Latmos et justement le
l'Atmos est derrière nous c'est ça aussi
la recherche française qui est présente
sur le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines
oui mais un avion moi je crois que
c'était ça qui me disaient que
sur arafal lui il n'a que 40% de l'avion
le reste c'est c'est plusieurs centaines
de de sous-traitants avec qui travaille
et donc un avion faut voir ça fait
marcher toute une sous-traitance
d'excellence aussi donc vraiment c'est
c'est c'est tellement simple pour
l'économie pour pour
c'était un tellement beau symbole puis
un avion c'est c'est beau en plus donc
oui vous êtes toutes les valeurs je
trouve la rigueur faut voir
pour une rigueur extraordinaire vous
savez c'est zéro faute en l'air vous
demandez une pièce à un sous-traitant
c'est zéro faute dans l'air bon faut
voir donc toutes ces excellence ça donne
ça donne courage dans dans dans la
France et confiance et et nous en tout
cas 50 ans on porte aussi mais on aide à
des formations des mieux formés les
jeunes sur beaucoup de secteurs
numériques qui touchent les robotiques
bien sûr un mot aussi sur le spatial il
y a deux startups présentent ici incubés
au ski cube constellation astrolab il y
a aussi bien évidemment l'activité
historique d'Airbus dans votre commune à
Élancourt autour du spatial et la
construction de cartes électroniques qui
vont dans les satellites ensuite c'est
aussi ça la complémentarité entre le
secteur aéronautique le spatial et le
militaire aussi oui bien sûr c'est tout
un tout un environnement autour d'un
avion avec toutes ces 50 PME et bien sûr
on le voit bien et alors en même temps
on a la chance d'avoir un niveau de
culture numérique très élevé à
Saint-Quentin vous le savez avec ce
qu'on est rentré dans Paris c'est clair
et qui est le numéro 1 mondial
première université mondiale
scientifique en mathématiques donc qui
est tout le champ du numérique donc vous
avez cette excellence là qu'on retrouve
dans notre université de Saint-Quentin
59 Paris c'est clair et donc notamment
un micro satellite un anneau satellite
comme on dit qui tourne qui nous donne
des informations en ce moment qu'on a
poussé qui nous donne des informations
deux fois par jour sur les variables de
climatiques pour mieux comprendre les
les indésicatess en ce moment que que
nous vivons nous voyons on investit
aussi là c'est vraiment le mélange de la
haute technologie scientifique numérique
pour pour lutter contre le réchauffement
de la planète aussi qui est un sujet
important donc on voyait on est ce monde
scientifique il est dans la solution il
est pas dans le commentaire parce que
tous ces gens qui font des commentaires
sur les plans de télévision c'est bien
mais c'est bien aujourd'hui on a besoin
de scientifiques de techniciens de gens
forts numériques et qui comprennent
l'économie qui trouve des solutions
plutôt que parler des problèmes
commenter des problèmes voilà nous on
est dans la solution et ce monde là est
un monde qui est associé c'est pour ça
que Saint-Quentin cette spécificité
c'est là pour ce laboratoire de
solutions Saint-Quentin merci
Jean-Michel fourgousse président de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et voilà vous
pouvez découvrir le stand de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec
l'excellence le laboie laboratoire des
solutions comme vient de le dire le
président ici au Bourget c'est jusqu'à
ce dimanche